five
jet kick just for uh just some
compression yep
oh oh it's him out of the back turn a
nice escape there from nobi followed it
up
oh my god oh that's going to whip money
no
wow he's going to take the third round
double what a call out there in that
rage art
four
right now he's working to get back into
the back into contention right now he
got the big counter hit so we'll see how
is he going to close this out oh my god
another low parry and casey looking to
kill he goes for the rage art might not
be enough but one more mix-up could do
it let's see what he does never mind it
wasn't
ever
never
three
to put all your cards on the table
oh and a big block
but now double
trying to still maintain the lead here
another blocked health he knew
he's building something up okay no no
more rage
two
go for the lead nice
he just needs that one big jump in
though but carrie uh oh tries to jump in
on him
final seconds mark man how is carrie
gonna close this one out he's trying to
get run away with it
oh my god he almost found an opening
there final seconds oh he got it enough
oh he went for the title but it was
enough
one
house
we're gonna come back
oh my god he can't oh oh he can't get
two meters and two meters
and he blocked that one already
this is going to be
he might be dead he's dead he is hella
dead oh no
that's true dang i can't believe
mr howard had this in him
[Music]
[Music]